I have to let you go soon I did want to
end on one unrelated question because
Zoe I'm very excited for what's around
the corner for you right now it is a big
deal you should be very proud and I know
there's a lot of people who can't wait
to see you in the MCU what does joining
the MCU mean to you personally but also
what kind of influence do you want to
have on that franchise that's a great
question
um I think
I was talking about this yesterday
actually I think as trans people you're
kind of
I mean growing up I didn't get to see
myself anywhere so I didn't really know
that I existed and especially not as a
in a superhero show or movie I think um
and so I think I just feel
deeply grateful and moved that um
little trans kids and trans teens have
something to look at and to know they
exist and to know that you know they can
have superpowers and that you know like
that's where we belong we don't just
belong in trauma stories on the fringes
dying in things you know like we we
belong there with the big guys so yeah
it meant a lot to me